twitter has permanently banned
my pillow ceo mike lindell's account
after he continued to repeat bogus
claims about donald trump winning
the 2020 u.s presidential election mike
lindell has been
really a fixture of disinformation he
first appeared
more prominently early in the
coronavirus pandemic he was up alongside
trump at one of the white house press
briefings
uh talking about how trump is a gift
from god and trump talking about how
mike lindell instead of making some of
his pillows is going to make
some ppe i never heard again about
whether mike lindell actually delivered
the ppe but that's at least what they
claimed back in
what was it maybe may or something like
that in any case
he became mike lindell became a major
player
in claiming that trump was about to win
that trump
actually won that they're going to get
biden out and trump in for a second term
and now twitter has decided to ban mike
lindell
over quote repeated violations of its
civic integrity policy
according to a twitter spokesperson
now because mike lindell has been
posting
so much of this stuff it's not actually
obvious
right now which of his exact posts
triggered this suspension in even better
news
lindell is up against the possible
lawsuit from dominion voting systems
we told you yesterday dominion voting
systems is suing rudy giuliani for 1.3
billion dollars
for his defamat they claim defamatory
claims about them
uh now mike lindell also may be getting
sued for his claims that dominion voting
systems
were part of some big election fraud
that he claims
exists but for which there is no
evidence he also urged
trump you might remember to declare
martial law in minnesota
to obtain its ballots and somehow
overturn the election here was mike
lindell quick reminder
at a pro-trump rally this was january
5th not january 6 the day of the
insurrection it was january 5th
talking about how trump will be
president from november 4th
on every day i have spent looking into
the election fraud i've worked with
sydney powell general flynn
all the guys with these machines these
experts and i can tell you
100 donald trump is going to be your
president for four more years
[Applause]
i have i have never ever ever said
anything less than 100 and just today
there was so much this morning
i was on the phone with general flynn
and just
even more evidence came out these are
going to be bonus evidence just to put
more people in prison
now of course no one is in prison uh joe
biden has been sworn in
and now mike lindell is under threat of
lawsuit by dominion voting systems
and suspended from twitter so you know i
got into a little bit of an argument
with people on twitter i believe that
the my pillow guy is dangerous
but he's dangerous not because of who or
what he is
he's made dangerous by an american
society
and culture in which lots of people fall
for the stuff he says so what i mean by
that is this
in a more normal world no one would pay
more attention to mike lindell than they
pay attention to the rantings
of that guy on the subway platform
who's screaming stuff about repenting or
whatever the case may be
in a more normal world this guy
wouldn't be alongside a president on
tv and having the platform that he has
because of american society and culture
and lack of education and media literacy
mike lindell ends up getting propped up
by trump himself by q anon types and
even by some of right-wing media so
the the the danger of mike lindell not
doesn't come just from oh it's someone
in a country of 331 million saying crazy
things
we have plenty of those people the
problem comes from the way in which our
society
is susceptible to falling four con men
like mike lindell
like trump on another level and that's
where the danger comes from so when
people say
this is just one dude how can you say
he's dangerous well he's dangerous as a
result of combining him it's sort of
like
you can have components to a poison that
by themselves aren't poisonous
when they come together it becomes a
poisonous brew
that's what we're talking about with
mike lindell mike lindell plus a
susceptible population
plus those who are susceptible that have
the ability to give this guy a
significant platform that's where the
danger comes from
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt
fit much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout